c'est l'heure de notre second débat vous
le savez débat de société le plus
souvent possible on fait le choix de le
décader de l'actualité du jour et on
revient sur cette proposition de loi
déposée le 18 avril dernier pour
instaurer un congé menstruel pour les
femmes souffrant de règles douloureuses
faut-il suivre l'exemple de l'Espagne
qui l'a instauré il y a un an pourquoi
l'endométriose est-elle encore si mal
soigné avant d'en débattre je vous
propose un exemple celui d'une
collectivité la ville de Saint-Ouen
ville pionnière où les femmes peuvent
poser deux jours d'arrêt sans retenue de
salaire c'est un reportage de Jonathan
du priez
Tanina a 36 ans et est atteinte d'une
endométriose sévère plusieurs jours par
mois ces règles très douloureuses
viennent compliquées sa vie au travail
les symptômes des règles c'est les
douleurs dans le bas du dos
[Musique]
il y a 10% des femmes qui sont en âge de
procréer qui sont victimes endométriose
et en tant que chef de l'administration
on ne pouvait pas ne pas agir donc on a
décidé de mettre en place ce congé
menstruel ça ne pouvait plus durer
nous sommes la France un pays de la
liberté l'égalité de la fraternité j'ai
envie de dire que c'était une décision
on ne peut plus républicaine autour de
Saint-Ouen les communes des lilas ou
encore Bagnolet sont en train
d'instaurer le même dispositif mais à ce
stade il semble plutôt réservé à des
communes ayant d'importantes ressources
financières et humaines si ce congé
tente à ce généraliser au sein des
collectivités des associations
féministes demeure circonspects pour
oser le féminisme la mesure serait
contre-productive reviendrait à un
visibiliser les douleurs menstruelles et
renforceraient la discrimination à
l'embauche alors l'association a une
proposition alternative créée en droit
pour tous les salariés femmes comme
homme d'être indemnisés sans délai de
carence dès le premier jour de leur
arrêt maladie ce qui permettrait aux
femmes et ont des règles douloureuses de
ça aurait été en étant indemnisé dès le
premier jour sans être discriminé à
l'embauche ou dans l'évolution de
carrière puisque l'employeur sachant que
un homme aussi peut partir en arrêt
maladie en étant indemnisé dès le
premier jour se poserait moins cette
question de se dire à un régime
spécifique d'arrêt pour les femmes elle
risque d'être plus absente donc je vais
la discriminer le débat autour du congé
menstruel a été relancé en France après
l'adoption en février d'une loi en
Espagne pour encadrer ce dispositif
Assemblée nationale et Sénat planche
actuellement sur des propositions de loi
similaires
le congé menstruel en France est un
progrès ou une fausse bonne idée on va
en débat tout de suite avec Hélène
condoé bourré bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes sénatrice socialiste des Français
de l'étranger Gaëlle Baldassari bonsoir
bienvenue créatrice de kiffe ton cycle
c'est une plateforme qui œuvre pour le
bien-être menstruel et qui lutte pour
que ça devienne une norme dans notre
société Xavier Molinier bonsoir
bienvenue à vous vous êtes directeur des
ressources humaines de la société good
days qui est pionnière dans notamment la
mise en place de ce congé menstruel
émise à Polski évidemment est resté à
mes côtés éditorialiste pour sens
publique quelques chiffres insondages
tiens que je vous propose pour ouvrir ce
débat sondage
Ifop du mois de octobre
dernier 66% des salariés
favorables au congé menstruel en
entreprise des salariés femmes 74 64%
des femmes concernées pour être y avoir
recours et 82% chiffre intéressant des
salariés craignent que ce soit un frein
à l'embauche ou à l'évolution des femmes
Hélène qu'on aimerait vous avez déposé
cette 18 avril dernier je crois une
disposition de loi pour instaurer ce
congé mensuel en France qu'est-ce que
vous proposez précisément
faites ce que nous proposons c'est un
cadre juridique qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui nous avons ici le maire de
Saint-Ouen qui l'a mis en place nous
avons monsieur qui a aussi décidé de la
mise en place de ce congé mensuel dans
son entreprise nous avons finalement une
mise en place de pour répondre à une
demande à une attente aujourd'hui dans
la société
je crois de quelque chose qui est
nécessaire et d'essayer d'apporter une
réponse un accompagnement à ces femmes
qui souffrent c'est un fait c'est une
réalité jusqu'à présent cela se faisait
dans l'intimité de celle-ci était cachée
restait cachés et parfois peut-être un
petit peu honteux c'était le moment du
mois où la femme était peut-être
irritable et à la douleur physique
s'ajouter peut-être aussi quelques
remarques désobligeantes de de certains
ou enfin je mettrai pas au féminin
d'ailleurs
de dans l'entourage de ces femmes donc
la motivation était de penser que sur le
dans le cas de législatif et bien nous
pouvions apporter finalement ce dont les
entreprises
pour que et bien
puisse se mettre en place ce congé
menstruel qui est pas tout à fait le
terme qui voudrait utiliser j'allais
venir parce que c'est imposé finalement
naturellement et tout le monde c'est
pour ça qu'on a utilisé en titre parce
que ça permet d'être prêt enfin voilà
que comme vous le dites que tout le
monde sache de quoi on parle sauf que
c'est pas le bon mot c'est pas un coup
ça c'est pas un congé c'est pas la DRH
du groupe Carrefour puisque le groupe
Carrefour est également introduit donc
parle plutôt d'absence rémunéré parce
que absence une absence ça peut être en
effet voilà parce qu'on est malade parce
qu'on est en congé parce que voilà on
est absent mais je pense que c'est quand
même moins
voilà
ça parle moins aujourd'hui que quand
j'ai menstruel où tout le monde sait de
quoi on parle finalement alors que
absence rémunéré pour règle douloureuses
et incapa et incapacitantes on va créer
un acronyme mais bon bref mais je suis
assez d'accord avec vous sur le terme
que le fait que congés mensuel ne
correspondent est-ce que vous y êtes
favorable vous galvanes
parce que je pense qu'il y a un vrai
besoin il y a des femmes qui aujourd'hui
tous les mois perdent des jours de
salaire parce que soit elle pose un jour
de congé mais ce qui revient à perdre un
jour de salaire soit elles ont des jours
de carence et donc ça c'est un problème
donc je suis favorable au fait qu'il y
ait quelque chose qui se mette en place
et merci de porter ce projet là
maintenant je suis mesurée parce que je
me dis est-ce que c'est le bon véhicule
de d'aller vers justement quelque chose
spécifique menstruel est-ce qu'il y a
pas dans nos sociétés des maladies
chroniques
existantes et non genré pour lesquels on
pourrait créer un véhicule de récurrence
qui permettrait d'éviter que ce soit
monstruelle oui vous dites attention à
une forme de discrimination c'est
harcèle paradoxe c'est-à-dire que c'est
un progrès et c'est une façon de sortir
de l'ombre ce qui était quand même un
thème totalement
passé sous les radars même médiatique on
aurait pas fait ce débat il y a 5 ans je
vais être très honnête avec vous
peut-être même il y a 2 ans enfin voilà
il y a une sorte de progrès dans la dans
la prise de parole mais vous dites
attention à la discrimination c'est ça
moi je dis attention à discrimination
attention à l'impact à l'embauche on
sait aujourd'hui que un employeur qui
emploie une jeune femme qui a des
probabilités fortes de tomber enceinte
va déjà faire une décote à l'emploi etc
on voit ces choses-là sur le terrain
moins bien la payer que quand on est la
masculin et tu vois c'est une question
sur l'avancement aussi de carrière parce
que si on s'arrête là si on s'arrête à
dire on donne des congés et tous les
mois les femmes qui souffrent de 10
semaines aurai vont être sur leur canapé
en train d'attendre dysménorrhée de
faire de la pédagogie ce sont des règles
douloureuses particulièrement
douloureuses c'est ça on va pas
on va pas régler le problème on propose
pas de processus qui va permettre d'en
sortir avant la ménopause et ça veut
dire deux jours par mois sur toute une
carrière on a une perte de chance
quelque part alors on y reviendra et on
se posera la question d'un dispositif
peut-être plus générale ou plus
ambitieux mais je voudrais bien avoir
votre retour d'expérience Xavier
Molinier vous l'avez instauré dans votre
entreprise à quoi il y a une année
pourquoi déjà pourquoi le point de
départ la genèse de la décision le point
de départ est assez simple c'est quand
on est entrepreneur on a l'obsession de
trouver des solutions aux problèmes qui
se posent et pour notre entreprise la
volonté c'est que nos salariés quel
qu'il soit se réalisent
professionnellement et on s'est posé la
question au moins effectivement de quels
sont les freins à cette réalisation
professionnelle mais qui ne serait pas
adressée aujourd'hui par une loi ou par
une obligation et effectivement on a
constaté que aussi bien je dirais
l'endométriose les règles douloureuses
ou la fausse couche était des cas qui
n'étaient pris en compte nulle part et
qui pouvait être un frein effectivement
de discrimination donc on s'est dit
autant innover prendre de l'avance sur
ce qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui et c'est
de montrer l'exemple pour faire en sorte
que ce ne soit plus une problématique et
qu'au contraire ça devienne quelque
chose de normal dans l'entreprise et
vous êtes une entreprise plutôt de la
tech avec avec des salariés plutôt
jeunes c'est ça c'est on a l'avantage
effectivement d'être dans la tech donc
d'être sur ce qu'on peut appeler
effectivement une catégorie plutôt CSP+
on a que des cadres dans l'entreprise la
moyenne d'âge est de 35 ans on est sur
une dynamique d'innovation permanente
donc effectivement c'est ce sont des
sujets qui sont d'actualité qui sont
acceptés assez facilement est-ce que
c'est aussi un argument pour recruter ou
retenir des salariés au départ ça
n'était pas mais de fait saler voilà
donc l'objectif c'était pas de retenir
les salariés avec ça ou d'attirer mais
de fait ça attire et ça retient
juste je trouve que c'est intéressant
parce que évidemment c'est on commence à
prendre en compte les spécificités des
femmes dans tous ces aspects là y
compris celui-là est-ce que je trouve
dommage c'est que c'est toujours en
négatif pour l'instant on reconnaît les
différences des femmes beaucoup en
négatif c'est à dire alors vous allez
avoir un congé maternité je suis désolé
l'enfant on le fait à deux normalement
enfin pas tout le temps mais voilà vous
allez avoir des règles douloureuses donc
vous allez avoir des congés on regarde
pas ce que peuvent apporter les femmes
sur un plan positif et différent c'est
comme si on découvrait les femmes et
qu'on se disait ah bah oui mais elles
ont oui mais elles ont ce problème là
elles ont ces problèmes là et on voit
pas l'autre face qui est je sais pas
après un congé maternité moi je l'ai
vécu on a très envie de changer on a
beaucoup d'ambition parce qu'on a
évidemment on a une organisation à mener
et peut-être que ça c'est aussi un atout
on sait que les femmes elles arrivent à
penser à 10 choses en même temps les
hommes c'est un peu relatif c'est très
sexiste que je dis mais bon dans ce sens
pour une fois je me le permet parce que
c'est écouté je vais pas la ramener donc
voilà j'essaie de te dire deux ou trois
tâches en même temps mais peut-être pas
10 je pense que ça par exemple on le
voit pas en entreprise la possibilité
justement d'avoir une nouvelle vie après
le congé maternité parce que on s'est
arrêté il y en a qui s'ennuient un peu
ou qui ont envie d'autre chose qui ont
vraiment une motivation et je trouve que
c'est dommage que ça soit toujours en
fragilité qu'on reconnaisse la
différence des femmes il me semble que
la prochaine étape ça serait justement
de voir on n'a pas beaucoup de femmes au
pouvoir ça c'est vrai de plus en plus
mais qu'est-ce que c'est le management
au féminin qu'est-ce que c'est la
présidence de la République au féminin
des choses comme ça et je pense que ça
peut changer et pas que eux en négatif
ou en fragilité alors je vais revenir
sur la question de ce que je vais
reprendre le terme congés mensuel et
notamment de l'endométriose pour essayer
là à ce moment du débat de savoir de
combien de personnes on parle ça
concerne combien à quel pourcentage de
femmes alors l'endométriose c'est une
femme sur dix en âge de procréé qui est
atteinte de de cette maladie et une
femme sur deux et là on sort du simple
cap de l'endométriose qui dit souffrir
de règles douloureuses elle a une condom
mourrait votre proposition de loi
elle elle vise toutes les femmes qui
souffrent de règles douloureuses pas
seulement l'endométriose pour essayer
d'être
précisons le terme dysménorrhée parce
que il est beaucoup plus large parce
qu'il y a bien sûr les douleurs
physiques qui sont liées aux règles mais
il y a tout un tas de symptômes qui sont
plutôt invalidants aussi pour la
personne qui se trouve dans un milieu
professionnel donc en fait ce que nous
avons souhaité faire c'est et je rejoins
totalement ce qui vient d'être dit
d'être dans le positif c'est-à-dire de
se dire que c'est une réalité c'est une
réalité à savoir que tous les mois il y
a des femmes en effet qui souffrent bien
qu'est-ce que nous pouvons faire pour
les accompagner et faire en sorte que en
effet il y ait ce geste et cette
confiance venant de la part de
l'employeur qui prend en compte le fait
que la femme était peut-être pas
opérationnelle à 100% pendant un jour du
mois ou pendant deux journées et met en
place finalement un système c'est à dire
de faire en sorte que cette femme puisse
rester chez elle et nous proposons par
exemple télétravail j'ai déposer un jour
de télétravail ce qui évite à la
personne de passer peut-être des moments
très désagréable dans les transports en
commun et c'est vraiment dans ce cadre
là de faire en sorte que la personne a
la possibilité de s'arrêter et de se
dire que au lieu de souffrir pendant un
ou deux jours et ensuite d'avoir encore
deux un ou deux jours suivants qui
seront peut-être compliqués de prendre
le temps de se reposer pour le temps
dont elle a besoin c'est peut-être une
demi-journée ces petites une journée
c'est peut-être deux et en fait d'être
opérationnel à 100% et de revenir un
petit peu plus ce qui est beaucoup mieux
répondez à la critique de l'effet
discriminatoire je
pense crimination aujourd'hui du fait
que on demande à ces femmes de gérer
toute seule leur souffrance de savoir
qu'elles ne sont peut-être pas au top
sur les 30 jours du mois et que il y a
cette discrimination qui est acceptée je
disais tout à l'heure dans le couloir si
les hommes ont souffert j'aime bien que
les discussions de coulisses viennent à
l'antenne si les hommes souffraient de
la même façon je pense que ça fait très
longtemps qu'il y aurait en place une un
accompagnement qui ferait que et bien ça
serait pris en charge ça serait pris en
compte et que là d'un seul coup parce
que justement il y a cette libération de
la parole ou on est un peu plus à l'aise
aujourd'hui parler de choses qui en
effet il y a 5 ans peut-être n'aurait
jamais été discuté ici et aujourd'hui il
y a plus les plus c'est pudeur on se dit
que il est possible en effet d'en parler
et surtout de se dire qu'il y a un
problème et que nous apportons des
solutions c'est quand même paradoxal de
se dire on est dans un dans un progrès
dans une prise de conscience dans une
sortie de tabou et de dire bah non moi
j'entendais là dans le reportage de
Jonathan bon après entendre
l'association
ou jamais contents
je vous rejoins complètement je suis et
on se l'ai dit tout à l'heure dans le
couloir justement je suis pour ce qui
est en train de se mettre en place je
dis juste attention à ce qu'on s'arrête
pas là parce que à mon sens si on
s'arrête là on va remettre en place les
conditions d'une discrimination et je
dis pas que on a trouvé une solution
donc c'est bon on en parle plus
inquiétude c'est ça c'est qu'on s'arrête
là en se disant ok on a trouvé une
solution et quelque part on renvoie les
femmes sur leur canapé elle se repose
moi ce qui m'inquiète là dedans encore
une fois c'est la perte de chance à
l'échelle d'une carrière c'est ça qui
m'inquiète et c'est là où je voudrais
qu'on apporte vraiment des solutions et
qui dit c'est pas suffisant en réalité
puisqu'elle s'arrête aujourd'hui de
toute façon
la chance de s'arrêter de façon acceptée
alors votre retour d'expérience là aussi
d'abord peut-être combien de de salariés
de l'entreprise en ont bénéficier depuis
un an et puis sur cette question
d'avancement de carrière de voilà
comment c'est perçu dans l'entreprise le
principe directement ça peut être
d'attaquer le sujet d'un point de vue
négatif au contraire la problématique
c'était comment est-ce qu'on donne à
chacun la chance de pouvoir se
développer professionnellement après
qu'on est des aspirations vers ça ou
vers ça qu'on soit homme ou femme
c'était pas la question mais c'est de
laisser à chacun d'irrer la possibilité
de pouvoir se réaliser et de pas
souffrir au travail bon ça c'est le
point de prendre le sujet par le côté
positif après ce qu'on constate au bout
d'un an c'est qu'on a on est dans la
norme je dirais nationale puisqu'on a on
a peu 40 femmes dans l'entreprise et on
a cinq femmes qui ont profité de de ce
congés
dans la norme nationale voilà et ce
qu'on a constaté aussi d'intéressant
donc nous on maintient le salaire à 100%
comme il n'y a pas de cadre légal c'est
sur déclaration de l'intéresser en toute
confiance donc on demande pas de ni
certificat ni quoi que ce soit et on
s'est rendu compte que au final il n'y
avait pas d'abus et que les femmes qui
ont profité le faisaient de manière
extrêmement
utile et en fonction de la situation
soit un jour un mois zéro jour le mois
d'après 2 jours le mois d'après il y a
pas de systématisation de l'utilisation
du congé
par contre là on est dans un cadre
privilégié d'une entreprise privilégiée
qui a mis en place les choses etc moi
qui vient par exemple d'une banque dans
laquelle il y a énormément de salariés
ce que je vois c'est les suspicions moi
je me souviens très bien une personne
qui était absente le premier jour des
des soldes par exemple qui étaient
suspectés d'avoir posé cette journée-là
en disant qu'elle était malade parce que
elle allait faire les sols ce genre de
petites suspicions à l'échelle de
grandes entreprises si on développe ça
en global sans se poser de questions on
risque d'avoir la suspension
qui est quand même le numéro 1 européen
de distribution est numéro de mondiale
si je ne me trompe prend une telle
décision voilà c'est il y a un effet de
masse quand même donc on dit on dit
super c'est un progrès quand même
carrefour pour moi c'est du périodes
washingt total washing d'accord comme on
dit greenwashing ok on est sur du
périodes je vais vous dire jamais
content
de cette dimension là prend une tête
bien sûr mais le propose uniquement
personne qui sont reconnues en quelle
qualité de travailleurs handicapé c'est
un poème de de la population qui est
concernée par les Disneyland qui
souffrent d'endométriose et reconnue
donc c'est déjà il faut souffrir
d'endométriose et non pas de
dysménorrhée et il faut pour cette ce
problème là être reconnu en qualité de
travailleuse handicapés c'est ridicule
aujourd'hui le nombre donc aujourd'hui
et en plus les mesures qui ont été
annoncées elles sont déjà possibles à
mettre en place pour n'importe quel
salarié et ou et eux qui seraient
reconnu en qualité de travail handicapé
donc pour moi on est dans le période
washing total
pour vous répondre mais j'entends
j'entends votre argument oui oui non
mais alors Émilie je voudrais qu'on
parle de de la façon dont finalement le
les politiques s'empare de de ce sujet
des règles aujourd'hui alors mieux vaut
tard que jamais on voit que ça commence
à arriver les règles ou pour être plus
soft les menstruations mais autant
appeler un chat un chat ou un pain enfin
leur apparition dans le débat public en
France il a fallu attendre donc des
milliers d'années pour cela les premiers
pas sont encore un petit mides alors
2016 la taxe tampon est instaurée donc
ça fait passer de 20% la TVA à 5,5% sur
des protections des produits périodiques
un pas important puisque sur les 15,5
millions de femmes qui sont concernées
par les règles près de 2 millions
souffrent de précarité menstruelle ça
veut dire qu'en gros elle choisisse de
temps en temps entre acheter des
protections hygiéniques ou bien un autre
produit de première nécessité donc on
imagine des difficultés 2020 c'est un
rapport parlementaire sur les
menstruations qui est publiée et le
verdict est assez clair on écoute l'une
des parlementaires
après des mois d'audition et de
rencontres une chose est sûre ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que les menstruations
c'est toujours un sujet tabou avec tout
ce que ça entraîne de honte de préjugés
donc là on est en 2020 2020 donc le
rapport propose de lever ce tabou il
propose une grande campagne
d'information des cours ou si ou des
informations sur le sujet dès la 6e au
collège une meilleure vérification de la
composition aussi des produits
périodiques une cinquantaine de
propositions on arrive à 2022 le plan de
lutte contre l'endométriose est annoncé
par Emmanuel Macron un sujet important
on l'a vu tout à l'heure ça touche plus
de 2 millions de Françaises les choses
donc s'accélèrent après plusieurs
milliers d'années et de tabou moi je
suis d'accord avec vous si ça avait
concerné les hommes ça serait réglé
depuis plusieurs années puisque on sait
qu'on a pas tout à fait la même façon de
supporter la douleur ça c'est mon
deuxième type ça existe à ce sketch très
drôle de Florence Foresti sur la
poussette et qui dit si c'était plus les
hommes on aurait trouvé un système tout
simple on fait bip et ça se ça se plie
tout seul et ça et ça arrange ça se
range dans le dans le coffre du de la
voiture je vous laisse terminer la
proposition de loi sur le congé
menstruel en tout cas vos propositions
ça montre que le sujet commence à être
pris en compte avec un aspect général
des nouvelles générations qui sont pour
quelque chose on a l'impression que la
nouvelle génération est beaucoup plus
libre pour parler de ces sujets du
clitoris et de tout ce qui concerne le
sexe féminin ou le corps féminin et
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
exemple avec une interview de François
Hollande donc ancien président sur
Instagram par l'association règles
élémentaires c'était il y a quelques
semaines
[Musique]
c'est une nouvelle qui vient donner un
chiffre à une réalité pour beaucoup de
femmes c'est un coup supplémentaire que
la nature leur inflige et que la société
ne le rembourse pas pour beaucoup de
femmes c'est donc un sujet d'inquiétude
ou même de grogne en disant pourquoi
nous sommes victimes d'inégalité
supplémentaire en dehors même de la
douleur que ça peut représenter donc
elle faisait réagir par rapport à toutes
les informations et tout ce qui est
tombé comme nouvelle règle du jeu
l'association avait d'ailleurs publié
une tribune à l'occasion de la
présidentielle 2022 pour faire réagir
les candidats au moment de la
présidentielle elle avait fait le compte
sur les 12 candidats à l'Élysée seuls
deux Valérie Pécresse et Fabien Roussel
pour ne pas les nommer avait des
propositions sur le sujet du type congé
de deux jours pour les règles ou
gratuité des protections périodiques
mais le chemin sera encore assez long
avec une difficulté à prendre en compte
et on en a parlé c'est ne pas
stigmatiser les femmes même si on est
maintenant loin de tuer de mauvaise
humeur tu as tes règles l'idée de créer
un congé spécifique fait un petit peu
polémique ou en tout cas ça nous fait
discuter puisque deviendrait peut-être à
discriminer un petit peu les femmes dans
le même esprit que le congé maternité et
d'autres sujets mériteraient aussi
d'être mis sur la table comme les
conséquences importantes de la pilule
contraceptive sur la santé des femmes
vous savez cette hormone qu'on prend
nous chaque jour pour éviter que les
hommes se posent trop de questions et ça
a des incidences quand même sur le corps
et sur la santé ou encore on en a parlé
tout à l'heure la qualité des
protections que les femmes utilisent
mais bon chaque chose en son temps
faudrait quand même pas aller trop vite
finalement c'est peut-être encore une
histoire de cycle tout ça merci beaucoup
et Emilie question de santé publique
gueule baldasser lui dit qu'il faut
aller plus loin même si c'est c'est un
progrès de l'instaurer un congé
menstruel ça veut dire quoi qu'est-ce
qu'il faut pour aller plus loin quelle
solution vous imaginez vous proposez
alors moi la solution que j'imagine
c'est de faire alors je suis passé le
bon terme mais on va dire un Grenelle du
cycle menstruel qu'on se met autour de
la table avec des médecins qui
reconnaissent ce qu'ils peuvent faire et
ce qui ne peuvent pas faire aujourd'hui
poser diagnostic et heureusement qu'ils
sont là clairement mais il y a toute une
zone grises de souffrance menstruelle
qui aujourd'hui n'est pas prise en
compte ou mal prise en compte il y a
d'autres praticiens alternatifs on peut
parler de naturopathe ou d'autres types
de métiers qui aujourd'hui apportent un
mieux-être mais sont un coup énorme pour
les personnes qui vivent ça et
aujourd'hui il y a pas de parcours
coordonnées donc si moi la proposition
c'est dire si une personne active
cette proposition qui est de dire je
prends le congé menstruel ça veut dire
qu'il y a un praticien de santé
sage-femme ou médecin qui a reconnu la
chose et bien moi je propose que ces
personnes là entre dans un processus
dont l'objectif soit qu'elles en sorte
le plus vite possible c'est à dire
qu'elles aient retrouvées le bien-être
menstruel ça sera possible pour
certaines plus long voire impossible
pour d'autres mais qu'en tout cas on se
donne la possibilité au-delà de l'arrêt
de pouvoir réellement aller vers un
bien-être menstruel vous ne demandez
même pas de certificat médical ou c'est
ça ça repose sur la confiance tout
repose sur la confiance et on veut aller
plus loin
en train de réfléchir avec notre
mutuelle justement à la mise en place
d'un système d'accompagnement pris en
charge pour la mutuelle en terme de
formation et de savoir sur qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette douleur parce que c'est
quand même une douleur très particulière
et donc il est important qu'il y a des
conséquences d'un point de vue
diététique médical gymnastique enfin de
sport donc ce qu'on veut c'est
accompagner plus loin encore que donner
ce seul congé alors il y a la question
effectivement de de la prise en charge
et des jours de carence j'aurais qu'on
fasse un petit focus là-dessus avec une
réaction celle de la secrétaire général
de la CGT Sophie Binet qui est fait
partie de de celles et ceux qui sont
réticents à l'idée d'un congé menstruel
elle propose d'autres pistes comme celle
de supprimer les jours de carence
faudrait plutôt supprimer jour carence
aujourd'hui en cas d'arrêt maladie on a
entre 1 et 3 jours de carence on n'est
pas payé pour les arrêts maladie le
problème c'est que les règles douloureux
c'est jamais plus de trois jours d'arrêt
donc systématiquement ça va être des
jours non payés comment vous répondez à
cette question des jours de carence
l'élément principal finalement de la
propos de loi c'est justement lever les
jours de carence le premier jour
absolument pas ces jours il faut savoir
que certains nombre de
Carrefour ça peut être n'importe quel
entreprise mais les femmes chaque mois
ne peuvent pas se permettre d'avoir un
arrêt maladie non payé de perdre un jour
de salaire c'est juste impossible donc
l'élément principal c'est justement
lever ce genre de carence et moi je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit il faut le placer finalement
cette pathologie dans dans d'abord dans
le long terme et puis dans le médical ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et en
auditionnant beaucoup de sages-femmes et
de médecins nous sommes rendus compte
que finalement il y avait peu de
médecins de généraliste qui comment qui
ont pris conscience de de
l'importance de de ces souffrances et
souvent les femmes finalement se
retrouvent avec un diagnostic qui dit ça
va passer de toute façon donc vous
attendez le mois prochain vous aurez la
même chose mais
donc là finalement ce que nous proposons
c'est d'avoir un arrêt maladie qui est
valable pour une année pour que les
femmes n'aient pas chaque mois à
retourner chez lui mais d'abord un bilan
finalement à la fin de l'année et pour
certaines de penser que ça sera
peut-être la première fois qu'elle dit
consulter avec un accompagnement
médicamenteux peut-être qui permettra de
les soulager et de faire rentrer
également dans le corps médical
finalement cette ce besoin de s'inscrire
dans le long terme et de se dire qu'il y
a en effet un certain nombre de
pathologies qui méritent aujourd'hui des
prisons différemment et les sages-femmes
sont beaucoup plus en pointes finalement
sur le sujet que les médecins que nous
avons pu auquel nous avons pu parler et
qui moi ça fait partie de ce que ce dont
on peut souffrir mais voilà
j'essaye de mettre les pieds en plat de
temps en temps je ne dirais pas comme ça
mais je veux dire c'est pas voilà c'est
pas traité c'est pas aujourd'hui dans le
radar de se dire
le corps médical doit pouvoir apporter
des solutions voilà des études qui
montrent que par exemple les infarctus
chez les femmes sont détectés au moins
rapidement parce que justement on
considère que les femmes ont un seuil
par rapport à la douleur plus importante
donc que ce soit les médecins ou les
femmes elles-mêmes regardent moins ça et
donc c'est moins détecté moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est la première cause
de mortalité
les douleurs de règles donc en fait
aujourd'hui il n'est pas rare d'entendre
encore aujourd'hui un médecin on va dire
c'est pas complètement anormal d'avoir
mal et donc ça c'est un vrai problème
parce qu'en fait normalement de règles
c'est vrai de la gestion de la douleur
en général c'est à dire que il y a une
prise de conscience
non mais c'est certainement accentué
parce que ce sont des douleurs
typiquement féminines je suis d'accord
avec vous mais la prise en charge de la
douleur par la médecine française elle
est relativement récente pour les bébés
je suis malade donc j'ai mal
on peut entendre et nous on a des femmes
qui témoignent de ça tous les jours
je suis allée chez mon médecin je lui ai
dit que je souffrais le martyre et on
m'a demandé si ça se passait bien avec
mes petits camarades à l'école par
exemple pour les collégiennes qui
souffrent des choses comme ça et donc en
fait on sent quand même que on va
psychologiser très vite les douleurs de
règles et donc il y a un manque de prise
en charge mais aussi par méconnaissance
c'est-à-dire que les médecins sont
parfois malheureusement démunis
et de femmes en fait il y a une question
de compréhension ça a été longtemps un
tabou donc en effet les hommes ça les
effraie peut-être ou il y a quelque
chose de et je pense que plus c'est des
problématiques qui sont prises en compte
entre hommes et femmes plus et ira loin
et je parlais tout à l'heure de la
contraception c'est la même chose on a
imposé aux femmes parce que c'était
pratique ça marchait bien et c'est vrai
que c'était une révolution la
contraception on voit quand même que ça
a des des incidences importantes
pourquoi les hommes n'emporteraient pas
aussi pourquoi ça serait que la
responsabilité d'une des femmes et
contraceptive il y a les préservatifs il
y a d'autres choses mais ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'il faut pas le le mettre
juste du côté des femmes comme si une
pathologie et débrouillez-vous c'est une
question de société qui émerge
maintenant parce que la femme se libère
et on parle plus de ça mais c'est une
question de société à partager ensemble
de le porter dans le débat public
finalement au Parlement c'est une façon
aussi de poser le sujet dans un cadre
médical dans un cadre en effet de
bien-être au travail et d'avoir un débat
qui soit sain finalement et qui aille
dans le de ce que vous proposez c'était
une vision globale mais qui s'inscrit
dans le temps surtout alors je reviens à
l'endométriose pourquoi il est si mal
diagnostiqué écoutez ce qu'on disait ça
va rejoindre ce que vous nous avez dit
un peu les unes les autres mais est-ce
qu'on disait la chanteuse Imany alors en
étant 2018 lors d'une manifestation on
s'imagine que avoir mal pendant ses
règles c'est normal donc si c'est normal
pourquoi est-ce qu'on va faire des
recherches pour améliorer la vie des
femmes je pense aussi qu'il doit y avoir
peut-être y a pas assez de femmes
chercheuse il devrait peut-être y en
avoir un peu plus
et que vous avez aussi c'est parce que
c'est un problème féminin ce serait un
problème masculin je pense qu'on aurait
déjà trouvé je sais pas si on aurait
trouvé la solution mais en tout cas il y
aurait des gens qui auraient travailler
à la solution cette phrase on leur
entendu plusieurs fois et c'est et c'est
normal je je la fais mienne alors on va
accueillir Audrey betas sur ce plateau
rebonsoir Audrey pour savoir si donc on
était en 2018 5 ans plus tard le
lendemain mitrioz est mieux
diagnostiquée en quelque sorte alors les
choses avancent un petit peu mais ça
reste tout de même très compliqué un
chiffre il faut en moyenne 7 ans
d'errance médicale en France entre les
premiers symptômes et le diagnostic
d'endométriose à ce sujet je vous
propose d'écouter un autre témoignage
celui de Marina Dano qui a été recueilli
par notre collègue Flora sauvage dans le
cadre de son documentaire sur les
inégalités de santé des inégalités des
femmes en matière de santé
en 2014 ça a été le début de l'enfer
j'étais à table avec une vingtaine de
bottes et d'un coup je sentais plus mon
dos ni ma jambe droite donc rendez-vous
médecin en urgence et puis le médecin il
me dit oh c'est une cruralgie t'attend
ça va passer sauf qu'au bout de deux
mois ça passait pas il y a pas
d'amélioration je suis partie voir une
ostéopathe en me disant ça a peut-être
m'aider un peu juste ça me regardait en
touchant et me disait mais tu sors d'ici
tu as une énorme ressort dans le ventre
je suis arrivé aux urgences
clairement l'interne il m'a regardé il
m'a rayonné et c'était vos douleurs
c'est des règles et puis votre ressort
je la sens pas
vous le voyez ça peut devenir le
parcours du combattant l'endométriose
est une maladie méconnue que l'on ne
s'est pas encore soigné on peut juste
limiter les symptômes pourtant on parle
d'une pathologie qui touche une femme
sur 10 en France alors pourquoi un tel
retard élément de réponse avec le
professeur Nathalie Massin elle est
endocrinologue à l'hôpital intercommunal
de Créteil
pendant très longtemps on a finalement
considéré que les femmes qui avaient mal
au ventre au moment des règles c'était
c'était tout simplement quelque chose
qui était physiologique donc derrière
physiologique on met normal et derrière
normal on met pas forcément beaucoup de
considération est-ce que la médecine a
porté moins d'attention d'une manière
générale
à la femme à la pathologie de la femme
c'est une question qui qui est posée
alors les choses avancent doucement je
vous l'ai dit depuis 2020 l'endométriose
est inscrite dans le parcours de second
cycle des études de médecine mais c'est
encore très compliqué notamment dans
certains départements qu'on considère
comme des déserts médicaux on manque
encore de médecins spécialistes j'ai
terminé par le témoignage d'une passion
dans le Berry qui dit dans mon
département l'endométriose n'existe pas
vous le voyez le chemin est encore long
merci beaucoup Audrey Gaël baldassaria
je termine là-dessus là sur le les
inégalités enfin en fonction de
l'endroit où on vit en France on est on
va pas être prise en de la même façon il
y a des endroits effectivement ça
n'existe pas on est encore là il y a des
endroits où les praticiens se sont
regroupés il y a des médecins différents
types de médecins des médecins écologues
qui prennent en charge la douleur des
médecins des chirurgiens qui vont si
besoin à faire la chirurgie et tout cela
se sont mis en place dans certains dans
certaines régions s'il y a d'autres
endroits où personne ne se parlent et
vous les femmes
et des autres quand les médecins font ça
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a il y a pas eu
d'impulsion politique
il y a une impulsion politique là
actuellement il est en train de se
mettre en place des parcours régionaux
donc il y a une impulsion politique mais
qui est toute récente donc en plus c'est
mis un peu à marche pas ça marche forcée
donc là ça court pour les mettre en
place mais c'est vrai que celle qui
existe aujourd'hui notamment je pense à
Nice ou à d'autres endroits comme ça ce
sont effectivement des initiatives de
médecins qui se sont spécialisés sur le
sujet et aujourd'hui on a des femmes qui
viennent de très très loin qui prennent
l'avion et qui vont rester parfois
quelques jours sur Nice pour pouvoir se
faire opérer je dis Nice mais il y a
d'autres endroits qui sont où il y a des
spéci existe comme ça mais parce que
effectivement les spécialistes qui ne
font que ça ce compte quand même ça doit
d'une main et donc le documentaire de
Flora sauvage d'où ont été extraits les
témoignages que vous venez d'entendre il
sera diffusé le 20 mai sur notre antenne
sur Public Sénat donc sur ce ces
inégalités en matière de santé des
femmes elle a une Congo mourez c'est
est-ce que la médecine est sexiste quoi
c'est la question c'est la question
qu'on peut se poser disons je pense
qu'elle a des progrès à faire
certainement et cela a été très très
bien dit et c'est exactement ce que j'ai
expliqué il y a quelques instants à
savoir que je pense que ça n'a pas été
prise en compte et c'est pour ça que le
fait d'aller consulter une sage-femme
les consulter un médecin va va faire en
sorte que le milieu médical va
s'intéresser je pense de plus en plus
à ces femmes qui jusqu'à lors ne
consultaient pas parce que elles ont
besoin de cet arrêt maladie pour pouvoir
justifier les quelques jours peut-être
qu'elle prendront dans le courant de
l'année est-ce que votre proposition de
loi elle trouve un écho auprès du
gouvernement est-ce qu'il y a parler de
volonté politique on en est ou de ce
côté là oui je enfin ça a été ça a été
proposé par le Président de la
République et je sais que dans la
majorité présidentielle aujourd'hui
c'est un sujet qui est important et pas
que je sais que le groupe écologiste
chaque année des pauses des amendements
également pendant le PLFSS donc le sujet
est là il s'instaure il
voilà je pense qu'il va trouver sa place
maintenant que le moment est prêt pour
que il puisse y avoir un débat serein et
qu'on puisse avancer et proposer à
toutes celles et tous ceux qui
souhaitent instaurer avoir ce cadre pour
ne pas bricoler chacun dans son coin que
cela leur soit proposé avec cette grande
flexibilité que nous avons proposé dans
le texte justement pour répondre aux
critiques mais je réfute quand même la
notion de discrimination ça me choque
profondément de penser qu'à chaque fois
qu'on essaie de faire un petit pas parce
que c'est un tout petit pas il faut
quand même faudra un peu d'humilité
de dire ah ben non ça va se retourner
contre les femmes mais non c'est fait
pour elle pour pour accepter que
le recruter
enfin je ne pense pas que la réalité
aujourd'hui du marché du travail ou dans
tous les domaines d'activité il y a
déficit de personnel qu'aujourd'hui les
patrons se disent ah mais le risque
d'avoir des règles douloureuses et de
risque d'avoir un enfant et se passer
d'une jeune femme qui arrive avec toutes
les compétences tous les talents se dire
que il a peut-être besoin de cette
personne plutôt que l'équivalent
masculin qui aura pas les mêmes
compétences ça c'est intéressant vous
l'avez un peu évoqué tout à l'heure mais
ce qu'on appelle la marque employeur
donc les entreprises qui qui font
attention à leur image auprès de auprès
du public et c'est vrai que d'être
montré du doigt pour discriminer des
femmes qui auraient pris des congés
menstruels en freinant leur carrière ça
serait ce serait de mauvaise évidemment
de mauvaise publicité je
j'ouvre une porte de défense une porte
ouverte en disant ça quoi
des disparités régionales il y a des
disparités d'entreprise bien sûr quand
on est une entreprise qui offre la
possibilité de faire du télétravail qui
offre un travail plutôt sédentaire assis
c'est un peu plus facile de faire
quelque chose que quand on travaille
dans la restauration dans l'hôtellerie
ou dans notre public et si vous avez des
collègues DRH qui qui prennent votre
exemple qui se dit tiens pourquoi pas
nous ou qui au contraire de pourquoi tu
as devancé la pelle
vous sentez qu'il y a un mouvement qui
commence à pointe c'est un vrai sujet un
sujet de société qui est pas seulement
un sujet de femme c'est un vrai sujet de
société qui va dans le sens de la de
l'égalité des droits des femmes dans la
petite qu'on a un index égalité
homme-femme aujourd'hui à respecter je
pense qu'il faut pousser continuer de
pousser et ça on est très fier nous
d'avoir pris un peu les devants
là-dessus est-ce que on va parler de
l'Espagne là dans dans ce débat parce
que l'Espagne est souvent présenté comme
un pays un peu pionnier est-ce que donc
c'était il y a il y a à peu près un an
le vote de la loi en Espagne est-ce que
ça vous a ça a été un déclencheur ça
inspiré au point de départ quand vous
avez pris la décision spirée sans doute
parce que c'est déclencheur je sais pas
mais inspiré oui de savoir qu'il y a
d'autres qui vont dans le même sens
c'est toujours encourageant de se dire
bah on se trompe pas complètement quoi
alors justement l'Espagne c'était il y a
un ange propose d'entendre la ministre
de l'Égalité qui portait cette loi
créant un congé menstruel mesure inédite
à l'époque en Europe portée par une
majorité un gouvernement de gauche pour
briser un tabou disatelle
nous sommes le premier pays d'Europe à
réglementer une incapacité temporaire
payée intégralement par l'État pour les
règles douloureuses et incapacitantes
plus besoin d'aller travailler en ayant
mal plus besoin de prendre des pilules
avant d'aller au travail et de devoir
cacher le fait que nous avons mal et que
nous sommes incapables de travailler ces
jours là toutes les femmes qui en ont
besoin pourront se servir de cette
incapacité temporaire quand elles auront
des douleurs qui les empêcheront de
travailler
alors je veux pas poser de colle je sais
pas qui peut répondre à la question mais
est-ce que là où l'une de vous a le
bilan de de cette loi en Espagne est-ce
que vous savez si ça a marché si il y a
beaucoup de femmes qui bénéficient de ce
congé menstruel en Espagne la loi a été
votée mais je crois que les décrets en
mettent du temps à sortir ça arrive
aussi en Espagne bien sûr
et je sais qu'il y avait une opposition
de la part des des syndicats parce qu'il
y avait pas une consultation qui avait
été faite et en effet c'est pour ça que
le terme de discrimination pour moi est
arrivé assez vite finalement dans la
prise en compte de de celle-ci
dans la levée de bouclier se dire voilà
on impose quelque chose et finalement ça
risque de se retourner contre les femmes
c'est pour ça qu'il faut le faire
différemment et insérer le plus de
flexibilité possible sur le type de
travail le nombre de jours maximum ça
veut dire que ne pas en prendre aussi si
on met un plafond enfin vous voyez ce
genre de choses alors que là c'était
deux jours voilà c'était pas ça a été
fait un peu rapidement je crois il y a
un autre exemple qui est sans doute
moins connu un autre pays pionnier en la
matière c'est la Zambie malgré les tabou
le gouvernement a fait voter une loi qui
autorise les femmes pas travailler quand
elles ont leurs règles un jour par mois
et alors par pudeur là-bas on appelle ce
jour la fête des mères
toutes les femmes ne prennent pas la
fête des mères en même temps ça tombe à
des moments différents si elles
partaient toutes le même jour alors oui
d'accord les entreprises fermeraient
mais ce n'est pas le cas et il n'y a
aucune preuve que la productivité soit
faible ou ait été affectée alors on va
parler de la productivité c'est aussi
pour ça que je voudrais que vous
puissiez entendre ce témoignage qui est
la une haut fonctionnait au ministère du
Travail de de Zambie ce terme employé
quand même la fête des mères ça montre
que bon le tabou il est encore là quand
même et elle Baldassari oui certainement
en tout cas moi je connais pas le
contexte culturel de la Zambie mais
clairement de toute manière en France le
tabou est encore là beaucoup de
personnes évitent le mot règles on a vu
tout à l'heure et oui le tabou est
encore présent maintenant il est en
train de se fissurer et moi j'aime bien
dire qu'un tabou c'est un consensus
social de silence donc si tout est tous
on décide d'utiliser les mots et d'en
parler ils vont tomber les règles sont
toujours bleues dans les publicités
comme ça
il y a eu des publicités avec du sang
rouge on a même une belle publicité avec
un vampire qui buvait dans une cup
menstruelle donc non non il y a des gens
on progresse là aussi le sport de haut
niveau il y avait une de l'équipe
notamment qui montrait je pense féminin
qui était l'équipe magazine rouge donc
voilà il y a aussi cette question des
athlètes sportives de haut niveau femme
et cette question-là de gérer en même
temps sa carrière avec ces moments-là
qui sont encore plus difficiles pour
pour ces femmes sur la question de la
productivité qu'est-ce que vous répondez
à ça à ce peut-être des des DRH des
chefs d'entreprise ouh là là je vais pas
y aller parce que on va perdre en
productivité
si vous obligez quelqu'un qui souffre à
venir travailler vous allez avoir
quelqu'un qui va mal travailler qui va
pas être heureux qui va râler et qui
derrière va vous détester et puis il va
pas être engagé dans l'entreprise si
vous permettez à cette même personne de
se reposer quand elle souffre et de
venir une fois reposer sans que ça pose
aucun problème vous allez avoir
quelqu'un qui va être productif engagé
enfin l'équation est très très simple
même envie d'aller un cran un tout petit
peu plus loin c'est dire que si je
prends vraiment ce temps de repos et
d'ailleurs je pense que c'est un peu
l'état d'esprit de la Zambie parce que
on n'a pas parlé de dysménorrhée on
parle plutôt de jours de fête des mères
et donc ce qui pourrait un peu le
premier jour des règles si on
s'autorisait à plus de repos et c'est ce
que je propose dans kifton cycle de
pouvoir un peu lever le pied ce jour-là
et bien on retrouverait potentiellement
plus de productivité par derrière et
donc la question c'est est-ce que
réellement c'est
enfin voilà c'est quoi
un peu fatigué exactement enfin pour moi
c'est
dans le mois un ou deux jours de repos
effectivement
persuadée qu'on va y arriver on voit que
c'est en train de se mettre en place
dans certaines entreprises pour la
marque employeur justement pour attirer
des talents et je pense qu'effectivement
de toute manière gagner en flexibilité
ferait gagner à tout le monde et
clairement pouvoir se reposer lever le
pied des jours on s'en fatiguait peut
permettre de faire remonter la
productivité drastiquement merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat qui était
passionnant vous pouvez nous retrouver
sur la plateforme Public Sénat point fr
cette émission nos émissions toutes les
émissions de la chaîne sont disponibles
en replay demain prochain rendez-vous
c'est dans la matinale rien de Mancini
qui reçoit Jean-François caraco le
ministre délégué à l'Outre-mer belle
soirée à toutes et à tous